trippy underwater scenes video game
comparisons and movie theater walkouts
Avatar 2 gave some viewers a headache
for a very specific reason following
James Cameron's groundbreaking 2009 film
Avatar the way of water face high
expectations from the start the Secor
needed to continue to build the ground
world of Pandora created by Cameron in
the first avatar but it also had to up
the ante when it came to visual effects
the first film was already considered a
major Game Changer but a lot of time has
passed since it was released as a result
viewers expected Cameron to use the
latest technology to break new ground
yet again now 13 years and hundreds of
millions of dollars later the
long-awaited sequel has finally been
released and what a sight it is while
the majority of critics don't consider
the film's narrative to be anything
spectacular the eye-popping visual
effects throughout savitar the way of
water have been the subject of
widespread Acclaim in fact one variety
film critic even wrote Cameron is raised
not only the stakes of his effects
artistry but the choreographic flow of
his staging to the point of making the
way of water like Avatar Into the
apotheosis of a must-see movie
[Music]
[Applause]
Fortress the sequel has received much
Acclaim for its sweeping Vistas and
dazzling textures but one aspect of the
film's visuals has received a mixed
reaction and that's the frame rate
needless to say James Cameron's latest
experiment was technology as yo did some
pretty passionate fan responses
paravatar the way of water Cameron chose
to change frame rates throughout the
film moving between the traditional 24
and the faster 48 frames per second per
variety many fans noted the switch up
with one redditor asking was I the only
one who likes the high frame rate I
thought it made the movie look even
better another writer to replied writing
I agree and the water scenes were
amazing I could watch Sigourney Weaver's
character Kiri interacting with nature
for six more hours for others though the
constant switching between frame raids
seemed to be the biggest complaint made
about Avatar the way of water one Reddit
sir was less infused for the change
writing the scenes with it looked really
cool but when it changed back to 24 it
looked really laggy in the theater I was
in the weren't so kind with one redditor
admitting I was expecting to hate the
high frame rates but I actually ended up
enjoying it and then hated other kept
bouncing back and forth between the 24
and 48 frames per second I noticed it
every time and it momentarily took me
out of the immersiveness one Reddit
server's especially Unapologetic when
describing scenes using the high frame
rate writing loaded like a video game
sequence awesome for a second then
stupid we walked out 35 minutes despite
the fact that some viewers weren't
impressed with the artistic Choice
Cameron's approach to the technique was
certainly labored over Avatar the way of
water is not the first film to
experiment with a higher frame rate
either Peter Jackson's Hobbit trilogy
and angley's Gemini man both played
around with different frame rates to
varying results the way of water Cameron
teamed up with the company pixelworks
and used their true cut motion platform
to manipulate the film's frame rate
during certain sequences to give the
film a crisper look and feel with the
team hoping that the technique become
more common plays for future films plus
CNBC when asked about the frame rate by
Yahoo Cameron explained we tried to
decide how to apply it and the rule was
whenever they're underwater it's 48
frames some of the flying scenes some of
the broad visitors benefit from 48
frames if it's just people sitting
around talking it's not necessary I've
spent thousands of hours underwater I'm
very literal about my underwater it
needs to look like it's real Cameron
also revealed that he spent a lot of
time deciding when to use the seemingly
controversial frame rate telling Yahoo
the trick is to figure out where to use
and where not to use it the one thing
I'll say pretty definitively is that 48
frames doesn't benefit a 2d movie very
much if at all it's really about making
a better experience than 3D regardless
of how viewers felt about Avatar the way
of water Cameron's long-awaited sequel
showcases as an ending hunger for
Innovation that is sure to have a ripple
effect throughout the industry
foreign